THAT HAS MORE RESONANCE AND
RELEVANCE.
SO HERE WE ARE.
WE ARE BACK.
AND WELCOME TO PRIME TIME.
THE JURY HAS THE KYLE ROURNS
CASE AND THEIR JOB GOT HARDER
TODAY.
I'LL XLAB WHY.
NOW ON ONE LEVEL THEY ARE DOING
THIS WITH 500 NATIONAL GUARD
TROOPS ON STAND BY FOR ANY UNRIS
IN WISCONSIN.
AND I HAVE TO REMEMBER THIS JURY
IS SEQUESTERED.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO'S DELIBERATING
YET.
YOU HAVE A GROUP JUST UNDER A
DOZEN PEOPLE.
THE JUDGE WILL DECIDE WHICH ONES
OF THE 12.
THEY'LL GO HOME AND TRY NOT TO
FOLLOW THE COVERAGE BUT THEY'LL
BE AWARE OF ALL THE WEIGHT OF
EXPECTATION JUST THAT'S HEAVY.
THE ATMOSPHERE IS TOUGH BUT SO'S
THE CASE.
THEY GOT A LOT OF CHARGES TO
CONSIDER.
AND THEY CAME AND GOT EXTRA ONES
TODAY AND GOT AN UNUSUALLY
CONFUSING SET OF INSTRUCTIONS
FROM A CONTROVERSIAL JUDGE WHO'S
AN ISSUE.
WILL HE BE FOR THEM?
WE'LL SEE.
NOW THE JUDGE THREW OUT A
WEAPONS CHARGE TODAY.
YOU ARE HEARING A LOT ABOUT IN
ONLINE.
LOOK.
THE STATUTE HAS A LENGTH FOR A
WEAPON TO TRIGGER NO PUN
INTENDED THE STATUTE WHERE IT'S
TOO LONG TO BE CARRIED.
THE JUDGE DETERMINED THAT THE
WEAPON THAT RITTENHOUSE THE
DEFENDANT HAD AN AR-15 IS NOT
LONG ENOUGH TO BE PROHIBITED
UNDERSTOOD THE STATE STATUTE SO
THE DOUBLE HOMICIDES AND ALLEGED
ATTEMPTED HOMICIDE HAVE LAYERS
TO CONSIDER.
WHY DOES THE PROSECUTION DO?
HEDGING WHY THERE'S MORE CHOICES
AND CAN BE CONFUSING FOR A JURY
ESPECIALLY WITH THE STRURKSS OF
WHAT'S OKAY AND WHEN AND IT'S
GOING TO EXTEND THIS PROCESS.
I'LL TELL YOU THAT NOW.
HOWEVER, AFTER WE HAVE HEARD THE
CASES AND THE CLOSINGS WE CAN
GIVE YOU THE MAIN QUESTIONS.
WAS THE DEFENDANT'S PRESENCE AND
THE BEHAVIORAL AT THE PROTESTS
OR RIOTS OR WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
CALL HIM, THE BEHAVIOR A
PROVOCATION TO THE PEOPLE AROUND
HIM?
THAT'S A KEY WORD.
WAS IT A PROVOCATION?
WHY?
BECAUSE IF HE PROVOKED AND
CREATED THE SITUATION YOU CANNOT
CLAIM SELF DEFENSE AS A CURE TO
A SITUATION YOU CREATED.
IF THE JURY DOES NOT BELIEVE
THAT HE PROVOKED THE SITUATION
AND THAT IS NOT UNLIKELY THEY
THEN HAVE TO LOOK AT EACH
INCIDENT OF A USE OF FORCE.
HERE THE FIRING OF HIS WEAPON.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO ASSESS
WITH EACH OF THE VICTIMS IN EACH
SITUATION SO MUCH TIMES IT'S
WITH EACH BULLET.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN HERE BECAUSE IT CAME IN
LESS THAN A SECOND BUT DID THE
DEFENDANT NEED TO USE DEADLY
FORCE TO AVOID SERIOUS INJURY OR
DEATH IN EACH INSTANCE HE USED
THE GUN?
IS IT REASONABLE TO THEM?
DOES IT MAKE SENSE?
DO THEY SAY IF IT'S ME I WOULD
HAVE?
THAT'S THE KEY.
WHAT ARE THE QUESTIONS IN
LOOKING AT IT?
WERE THE PEOPLE CHASING HIM?
TRYING TO HURT HIM?
WERE THEY TRYING TO KILL HIM?
PEOPLE OBSERVING THE CASE
OUTSIDE THE JURY GOT REALLY
STRONG FEELINGS.
SOME OF THEM DON'T MEET THE
FACTS.
ON THE LEFT KYLE RITTENHOUSE THE
DEFENDANT WAS FRAMED EARLY ON AS
AN ABSOLUTE VIGILANT, A VILLAIN.
HE IS A RIGHTY, AN EXTREMIST
LOOKING TO SHOOT PROTESTERS THAT
NIGHT.
SOMETHING EVEN HE ALLUDED TO
POESK CLI A COUPLE WEEKS EARLIER
CAUGHT ON VIDEO SAYING, HEY, YOU
SEE THOSE LOOTERS?
I WOULD HAVE SHOT THEM.
THE JURY NEVER GOT TO HEAR THAT
AND WE DID.
THE RIGHT PAINTS HIM AS A
VICTIM, A HERO.
HE ACTED IN SELF DEFENSE.
WHEN THAT MOB CAME AT HIM.
I HAVE SAID THIS ALL ALONG.
OKAY?
THE COVERAGE OF THIS SITUATION
HAS NOT BEEN GREAT.
IT'S STEEPED IN POLITICAL
AGENDAS.
THIS WAS NOT AN EASY CASE FOR
THIS PROSECUTOR AND THIS
PROSECUTOR DID NOT DO A GREAT
JOB.
OKAY?
NEITHER OF THESE PORTRAYALS HAS
TO FIND A HOME ON THE JURY AND
IT COULD BE THE CASE THAT THE
DEFENDANT WHILE HAS NO EXPLICIT
BURDEN, IT IS ON THE
PROSECUTION, BUT HIS TEAM MAY
HAVE MADE AND WITH HIM IN THE
CHAIR A STRONGER SHOWING IN
THEIR AFFIRM TIFF DEFENSE CASE
THAN THE PROSECUTOR DID IN
MAKING THEIRS AND MEETING THEIR
BURDEN.
REMEMBER, EVERYTHING THEY PUT
OUT ABOUT HIS SELF DEFENSE WAS
THEIR CHOICE BUT HERE IN THIS
COURT THE PROSECUTION HAS TO
PROVE TO THIS JURY BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT HE DIDN'T NEED
SELF DEFENSE.
THE MAIN TAKEAWAY A PROVOCATION.
THAT'S THE HEADLINE OF THE
CLOSING ARGUMENT.
PROVOCATION INVALIDATES THE SELF
DEFENSE CLAIM.
LISTEN.
>> YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO RUN
AROUND AND POINT YOUR GUN AT
PEOPLE.
THIS IS THE PROVOCATION.
>> THIS IS WHAT WE SEE IN THE
VIDEO.
HIM PUTTING THE FIRE
EXTINGUISHER ON THE GROWN AND
THEN RAISING THE GUN.
THAT IS WHAT PROVOKES THIS
ENTIRE INS DEN AND ONE OF THE
THINGS TO KEEP IN MIND IS THAT
WHEN THE DEFENDANT PROVOKES THE
INCIDENT --
>> THINK BACK TO BACK ON
NOVEMBER 2nd WHEN THIS CASE
STARTED?
DID YOU HEAR ONE WORD ABOUT
PROVOCATION?
YOU DIDN'T.
BECAUSE IT WAS NEVER SAID.
BUT WHEN HIS CASE EXPLODES IN
HIS FACE NOW HE COMES OUT WITH
PROVOCATION.
>> NOW, THAT'S NOT THE DEFENSE'S
BEST PUSH BACK.
THE BEST PUSH BACK IS THAT YOU
DIDN'T HEAR THE PROSECUTOR SAY
WHO DID HE POINT THE GUN AT?
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE GOING TO
PROVOKE SOMEBODY YOU'RE GOING TO
POINT THE WEAPON AT THEM.
THEY HAVE TO PERCEIVE YOU DO THE
P
PROVOCATIVE ACT.
DID THE PROSECUTION MAKE THE
CASE BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT
TO THAT JURY THAT IT'S
RITTENHOUSE WHO STARTED WHAT
WOUND UP WITH HIM FIRING THE
WEAPON AT THE SAME PEOPLE?
DID HE DO THAT?
WHY RITTENHOUSE WAS IN KENOSHA
THAT NIGHT, SO COMPELLING IN THE
MEDIA, TO SO MANY OF YOU
WATCHING THIS?
CAME ACROSS STATE LINES.
AR-15.
LYING THAT HE WAS AN EMT.
PROSECUTOR SAYS THAT ALL MAKES
HIM AN AGRESER.
LISTEN.
>> HERE'S THE DEFENDANT RUNNING
IN BETWEEN THOSE PARKED CARS,
SLOWING DOWN AND YOU CAN SEE
JUST HOW CLOSE OR RARTER HOW FAR
AWAY MR. ROSENBAUM WAS WHEN THE
DEFENDANT SHOT HIM.
MR. ROSENBAUM IS NOT EVEN WITHIN
ARM'S REACH OF THE DEFENDANT
WHEN THE FIRST SHOT GOES OFTEN.
THERE'S NO WAY HE COULD HAVE
TAKEN THAT GUN.
HE IS ALREADY FALLING TO THE
GROUND.
YOU CAN'T CLAIM SELF DEFENSE
AGAINST AN UNARMED MAN.
>> YOU CAN CLAIM SELF DEFENSE
IT DEPENDS ON WHAT THE UNARMED
MAN IS DOING TO YOU.
JUST BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE GUN.
BUT WAS IT REASONABLE.
IS WHAT HE PERCEIVED REASONABLE
IN THE MIND OF THIS JURY THAT IT
NEEDED TO BE RESPONDED TO WITH
DEADLY FORCE?
BECAUSE REMEMBER, HE ADMITTED ON
THE STAND I USED DEADLY FORCE ON
PURPOSE.
AGAIN REMEMBER THIS JURY'S GOING
TO HEAR ALL OF THIS.
THE JUDGE SAYS DON'T LISTEN TO
THE IMMEDIATE GENTLEMAN THEY'RE
NOT SEQUESTERED.
THEY GOT PEOPLE AROUND THEM.
THEY GOT LIVES.
SO MUCH NOISE ON THIS.
WHAT WILL FILTER THROUGH?
WHAT WENT?
NOW, DOES BEING IN CKENOSHA, THS
IS THE DAMNING FACT, HE WENT
THERE FOR BAD REASON AND HE'S
GOT BAD IDEAS IN HIS HEAD.
EVEN IF THAT'S ALL TRUE, DOES IT
MEAN HE PROVOKED THE ATTACKS ON
HIM?
THAT'S WHAT THE DEFENSE SEIZED
ON.
HERE'S THEIR REBUTTAL.
>> WE DON'T PLAY FAST AND LOOSE
WITH THE FACTS.
PRETENDING THAT MR. ROSENBAUM
WAS CITIZEN "A" NUMBER ONE GUY.
HE WAS A BAD MAN.
HE WAS THERE.
HE WAS CAUSING TROUBLE.
HE WAS A RIOTER.
AND MY CLIENT HAD TO DEAL WITH
HIM THAT NIGHT ALONE.
>> MR. ROSENBAUM WAS SHOT
BECAUSE HE WAS CHASING MY CLIENT
AND GOING TO KILL HIM, TAKE HIS
GUN AND CARRY OUT THE THREATS HE
MADE.
>> THE DEFENSE ATTORNEY ACTUALLY
SAID -- I HAVE NEVER HEARD THIS
BEFORE.
I'LL ASK IN A FEW MINUTE HE SAID
HE'S HAPPY THE DEFENDANT SHOT
AND KILLED MR. ROSENBAUM BECAUSE
IF HE HAD N'T HE WOULD HAVE
TAKEN THE WEAPON AND USED ON
OTHER PEOPLE.
A CLOSING ARGUMENT HAS TO BE
ANCHORED TO THE FACTS BUT THIS
JUDGE WHO YOU KNOW COULDN'T FIND
ENOUGH OPPORTUNITIES TO TALK LET
THEM GO AND DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING.
THAT IS A HUGE LEAP FOR THIS
JURY.
I WONDER IF IT BOTHERED THEM
BECAUSE THERE'S NO FACT TO
SUPPORT THAT.
THE ONLY REASONABLE THING TO
ARGUE IS THAT HE WOULD USE IT ON
RITTENHOUSE.
RITTENHOUSE'S MOTHER HAS BEEN
THERE, HAS BEEN EMOTIONALLY
OBVIOUSLY BUT ALSO WORKING THE
CASE IN THE MEDIA SAYING THAT
GUN THAT HER SON HAD THAT THEY
SAY IS A BAD THING IT SAVED HIS
LIFE.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE SHOULDN'T
HAVE BEEN THERE AND HE BRUNG
THAT GUN FOR PROTECTION.
TO THIS DAY IF HE DIDN'T HAVE
THAT GUN MY SON WOULD HAVE BEEN
DEAD.
>> NOW REMEMBER HE HAD NO
BUSINESS BECOME THERE.
HE SHOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN THERE
AND YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE TAKEN
HIM.
SHE DIDN'T TAKE HIM.
THE FACT THAT HE SHOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN THERE IS NOT WHAT THIS JURY
IS LOOKING AT UNLESS THEY SEE
THE PRESENCE AND BEHAVIOR THERE
AS PROVOCATIVE TO THE SAME
PEOPLE PROVOKING THE SAME PEOPLE
WHO CHASED HIM.
DID THE PROSECUTION PROVE THAT
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT?
NOW, LOOK.
YOU CAN ARGUE IF HE DIDN'T HAVE
THE GUN TWO MEN WOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN KILLED AND ANOTHER'S ARM